hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I am your host grace and
Helbig get ready for another very
exciting episode today we're talking to
Craig mini Ladd Thompson you probably
know him more as minilab he is a gamer a
philanthropist
he's a positive guy with a good attitude
and we get into all sorts of fun
conversations from the beginning of his
YouTube career and his surfing channel
not web surfing like actual surfing but
not surfing in an ocean surfing in those
you know manmade wave park said that
that's at water parks yeah we'll get
into all that it's all very real we also
talked about his his gaming community
and what that's like I don't know very
much but he taught me many things
stand-up he's also into that world which
is very cool and just you know what it's
like being a youtuber in the world now
it's the tough situation but he's got a
pretty good outlook on it and this is a
really enjoyable conversation so enjoy
this episode of not too deep with Mini
lad Craig hello hello thank you for
being here
you're very welcome thanks mate of
course you're a bit of an international
man of mystery to me in looking you up
you're you're a bit of a internet
Renaissance man yeah well here's the
thing everyone that I interviewed that
wears many hats that does many things
the first thing I ask them is what's
your deal oh god whilst my policy god
knows I can swear [ __ ] knows that [ __ ]
is my god so it's a suit so how do you
describe what you do to someone that's a
complete stranger um God okay
I mean youtuber yeah influencer all
those buzzwords and then I guess fill
out the post musician weird
foreigner god yeah that's great lots of
slashes lots of dashes on yeah no tick I
want to know a little bit about how you
got to where you are now so you were
born in Dubai as the walls yeah okay you
were born in Dubai but you you're not
you're from Northern Ireland yeah yeah
you're currently in Los Angeles yep
okay so take me through that trajectory
how does that work I was born I was born
in Dubai and 1985 I'm 25 now and I lived
there for five years my dad was no oil
business so just for his work I just
traveled around everywhere so accent
just sounds wrong like the interview yet
you're like oh that's different
no it's it's fun because I was watching
a bunch of your videos and I was trying
to place an accent I know it's it's a
hodgepodge but you can hear bits and
pieces everywhere so it's like a mud
it's a little combination of everything
so I was born in Dubai I lived there for
five years then I moved to Thailand for
a few years st. Singapore for three and
then whenever I was going into middle
school I'd call a secondary school you
guys called middle school then I went to
Northern Ireland because my parents were
like okay let's just sit you down
somewhere so if you just try and get
some kind of an education and then 2013
I went to college for two weeks to do
music brunches I know I went there and
it was the cause it was the same week
that GTA 5 came out and I was like okay
I can't upload Internet videos because I
have no internet in my dorm room for
three months I can't play rugby which is
a big thing for me my lectures were just
kind of whack period so I just went but
I don't remember University I got drunk
for like two weeks because it was the
University of Hertfordshire which is
just about London so I was the 18 to
drink so whenever here in the UK the
beautiful thing about colleges and
universities as they will get
celebrities to throw nightclub parties
for you like wait they'll be like
universities all like have like alcohol
sponsors it's fantastic this blows my
mind so they have alcohol sponsors and
they have celebrity hosted events for
the students yeah so like there was one
when I was there there was a rapper
called Tinie Tempah who it was really
big in the UK I don't know if he made it
over here or not but uh they're just
like special guest at 2:00 p.m. be here
we're like okay p.m. afternoon yes just
after lunch so he came along and no
really note was going on the Tinie
Tempah came out and then they realized
the whole entire event was sponsored by
copper bird so everyone's just getting
wasted on cider just after lunch I'm
like great education at its finest yeah
in the UK the the everyone goes to
college a week before the exam start and
that's called freshers week and that's
just a way for everyone just to get to
know each other and just get drunk with
each other and just figure everything
out so right when I tell you all my I
was university I went for an extended
freshers I went for an extra week still
got drunk and then came home and made
four cooks great you did basically the
expedited version of college you got it
all out of your system in like two weeks
and they exactly I'm like okay I get the
party thing I want to go work but wait
so you were into gaming and that whole
world before you started school oh yeah
I mean my gaming period I mean I've been
playing games on my life it's just it's
just my way of escaping things you know
from ember living in Singapore playing
counter-strike in land centres in
Singapore planning is like a bunch of
Chinese guys and just getting smashed
smack I remember fixing up my parents
windows 98 PC the giant brick that was
like school stuff and then I started
seeing people online in like 2008 I want
to say start making videos I was like I
could do this so I had a surfing channel
which surfing like okay so on the
Internet
so surfing as in you know when you go to
water parks they have those like
simulated surf machines yes all [ __ ]
thing one guy where they're lining up
and does like flips and tricks and [ __ ]
oh okay well kudos to you for finding
such an underrepresented niche of
entertainment for people's nations only
I mean and also I'm trying to wrap my
around how you even film that kind of
thing yeah no one else oh my god that's
incredible
my mom she loves taking she's a
photographer mom where she photograph
every every aspect of her life already
so I was like I just record this one
pouring yeah that's incredible and how
long did that beautiful career last you
know shocking enough not long at all
did you do you have to get like tickets
and admission to the water park every
time you want to shoot another video in
there I record like five videos and I
stuck filed them so like every two weeks
I would upload a different surfing video
to like 15 people
that was like fifteen bees apiece and
everyone at the water park is like that
kid is back with his mom and they're
filming more that's incredible
amazing do you remember the first game
you played that made you think like this
is I love this probably the original the
original pokemons on gameboy color I do
it's it was so it was the fact that you
can have like a handheld story I know it
sounds so weird but like whenever gaming
wasn't really well it's always been a
thing but when it's really evolved
whenever I could go around have my own
pokemon have my own story have my own
whatever but also like in my hand blew
my mind that's kind of like an extended
movie but I was the guy controlling the
movie I was like this is sick so
interesting cuz I'm not in the gaming
world I try to play games and it just
doesn't click with me so I'm always
fascinated by people that really love
gaming because I know that there's
something beautiful about it I haven't
found that for myself I tend to you know
to find Beauty and The Real Housewives
but I I get that I get that like your
handheld little narrative that you get
to be the god for lack of a better word
yeah like it's a movie you sit down yet
really doing what you can
but with gaming it's like you know even
though you know it's gonna end the same
way you can go around you can mess
around in the buildings or go do it you
want then you are
you are the protagonist in the story
that's so yeah like power I guess you
could say that maybe fall in love with
it yeah you're a power-hungry 13 year
old I get that power-hungry 13-year old
mum recording it all adds up yes
okay so you're doing these surfing
videos and then you you do you grow up
you go to college you get YouTube is
starting and you kind of see the light
and you're like schools not for me and
that's where you put your energy back
into actual like I'm gonna create a
youtube career situation yeah so the
mini lat Channel I started 2011 and I
was just kind of slowly building that up
as as high school kind of finished
quickly those who don't know mini lad
how do you explain that so many lies the
name came from whenever I was like 6 or
7 years old I had like a six-month spell
living in Northern Ireland before I went
back out to Thailand and my next-door
neighbor his name was also Craig my full
name is Craig Thompson and when were 6
years old we're like we're gonna call
you maybe because they're smaller okay
that's it
I just kind of stuck and then his
younger brother was the same year as me
in middle school and high school so he
was so used to calling me mini
everyone's like what does Kyle keep
calling you mini so it just stuck from
there
so she's mini mini thrown out and then
the last part came from an xbox xbox
live gamertag where I was just made a
few friends we wanted to change our
names to the same thing so there was
Kyle lad Conor lad Wayne lad and then me
mini light and thus and that's it's born
I came out okay so you start doing these
videos you're getting more into it take
me through that the beginning of this
yeah so I was just messing around on my
parents laptop I remember however going
to school coming back from school making
a Minecraft video not knowing how to
edit so I was editing on After Effects
on a $200 PC for 2011 which is garbage
so it took me about nine hours to render
the video and then I woke up and then I
uploaded the video because my parents
didn't really have good internet it
would take about eight hours to upload
it so the time I go back to the school
the next
it would finish uploading so I upload
the video and then record the next one
and that cycle that's dedication and
then 2013 came along I dropped out of
university because the same week I went
to university gta5 came out and that was
what kind of took me for nothing to
everything so I remember working on an
LA timezone in northern island for two
years so I woke up around 7 p.m. and
then went to bed around 11:00 a.m. I
thought I did that for about two years
straight so and that's to play the game
because everyone else was on at that
time playing this game yeah exactly all
people who I played with were American
those a few Irishmen like those like
Brian Terrorizer who I used to play with
and me and him cuz he lived down in
Dublin and I lived up in Northern
Ireland so I remember we would grind out
and then I would go to school the next
day and then he would go work at Subway
7:00 in the morning playing grinding
grinding granite and then go to work in
school yeah wow that's incredible
ok so when do you move to Los Angeles
that when does that happen or to move
2015 I knew that during the time that I
was working the night shift that was
like I just can't do this anymore you
know I didn't really have a morning as
such I woke up I used to go to Starbucks
to get my coffee in the morning that had
my pre-workout before I go to the gym
and then chug a monster before I
recorded an edited so my body's dying
it sounds like ok I need to go to where
the Sun is so I moved 2015 I only had a
6-month work visa so I left again and
then July 16 s when I got my official
proper three-year work visa and network
illa Wow congratulations thank you how
has Los Angeles changed you oh I mean
I'm still as white as ever I mean
everyone's like oh you live in
California oh my god you're like suntan
and beaches I'm like it's a nice like 68
degrees in this room at all times
ya know it's it's been incredible I mean
just I mean you know it's like she's
coming over here then you go plug got a
bunch of friends over here you get a
relaxed whenever you're not recording
you get to just chill with your friends
and it's nice you know
you can't do that when you're living
anywhere else that's very true
do you notice any because I don't really
know the gaming community very well is
there similarities differences between
like the general YouTube community
versus the specific gaming community um
I mean gaming communities a lot more me
me in the sense yes I love like we like
to joke around we like to do dumb [ __ ]
you know whatever the hell but I feel
like with like just from what I've seen
from the outside of the makeup industry
in the blog industry and everything like
that it's the fans are a lot younger
yeah but they're also a lot quote
hormonal sensitive yes yeah very very
careful with what you say like for me I
had a card to gets Humanity series that
everyone really enjoyed and that's
talking about you know Hitler jokes and
really excessive things like that well I
feel like you wouldn't be able to do
that in the flower community because
everyone there there's there's people
are sensitive but there's two different
kinds of sensitive if that makes sense
yeah I agree and I think we're
experiencing it a lot more obviously now
than ever before it's a lot worse yeah
it's very interesting and you've been
doing this collectively what like ten
nine years ten years something like that
nine years actually nine years next week
on the maila channel and then twelve
years altogether wow that's so bonkers
does that blow your mind they even stop
and think about do you have a second to
stop and think about that ever oh my god
yeah it's I think the weird thing and
you you might have got the circular I
know you've been around for a while is
people coming up to you and saying oh my
god you were my childhood I'm like I
just yelled a camera come up and say
that it's crazy it blows my mind you're
like I just was in my room I remember I
watched one of your videos a while ago
it's actually going into the segue of
what I was gonna tell you oh yeah I
remember those a video I saw you were
you're like showing people how to set up
your camera and use like your giant
window is your natural light you're like
your daily grey shows whatever I
remember whenever setting up my camera
because I want to do vlogs that I went
to your
video because the thing is I found you
because living in LA in 2015 I lived in
Playa Vista and there was a gigantic
billboard above me with your face on it
it was you and Hannah hearts it was
above me 2 million billboards are in
there so ever so I walked outside it was
just your giant well I apologize on
behalf of that obnoxious advertising
what a weird thing but thanks for not
defacing the billboard I appreciate it
ok in the gaming world I've been
watching bunch of videos your energy is
just so infectious it's so charming it's
so lovely you seem to be able to be
sarcastic and deprecating but still in a
relatively like positive happy way yeah
I wonder because this is something like
I've gone through and I've talked to a
lot of other creators that have gone
through like the putting yourself out
there for so many years how do you now
sort of if you do it all separate like
your personal life and how much you put
on the internet like have you had a
moment where you have to kind of like
compartmentalize like how much of
yourself you've been putting out there
yeah I mean you know we're looking too
much into it you know me and my
girlfriend well now actually broke up in
January and it was the whole thing of
like how much do we tell people online
right how do people because you also
don't owe anyone any information at all
right because for me it's like you know
my you know my fans are my life to a
certain degree where I want them to know
what's going on I feel like there's a
lot of things that I love people don't
know like you know I've been going
through a lot of personal stuff the
family stuff but no one knows about it
just because there's no point for me I
try and think of myself as someone who
likes to joke around and someone who
could be like a positive force so
whenever I tweet or do dumb stuff you
know I try and I try to keep a smile I
try and like make people happy if I just
keep tweeting about how sad I am or the
stuff going on my personal life it's
gonna bring them down so they see you as
someone who just complains a lot
who just this thing that thing I don't
want to be that Oh whatever people think
about me I want them to kind of think in
a more positive light compared to just
someone who can place all the time no
that's great I also think that there's a
huge amount of respect that's owed to
someone that's able to keep their
private life for themselves because they
know and we've all seen different
creators go through trauma of exposing
too much and then you can't take it back
so being able to same starves entire
career yeah I've watched so many
creators do that and it stresses me out
by proxy just watching that happen
because I'm a pretty private person I'm
in my personal world and so what and the
internet makes it so easy to share
absolutely everything Xers exercising a
little bit of restraint is more
difficult than people know I think oh I
give you I give you total props for
being able to be like here's the
headline of what's happening with me but
you don't need to read the rest of the
article right now right I mean what I do
is I'll literally sell my phone and I'll
type out a tweet that I really want to
send say like I'm angry something or
something like that I'll just type it
out I take a breath I delete it I move
on yes actually a great life hack for
anyone out there struggling with what to
put out there exactly I think that's
fantastic
okay so because you have this you know
new media job in this whole new media
world what's like a normal day like for
you I know normals not the right word
but what's like an average day like for
you yeah I mean I woke up and then well
for today I woke up now I'm here
normal try and get like some kind of a
workout in the morning it's working out
at home as a nightmare it's just fun I
agree and you also share a lot of your
like fitness journey stuff with people
which i think is very cool yeah because
for me before I was a YouTube a youtuber
I was very close to being a professional
rugby player I'm back in Northern
Ireland so that was kind of like that
was my aim in life was to try and do
something sporty and then I had a really
bad back injury that kind of ruled me
out of everything
so with that I put all my attention to
YouTube but because of that it's like
how do I describe it it's it's the idea
of trying to show as much as you can but
also keeping as private as you can okay
I have a question for you you're a very
private person what's it like going on a
podcast and do like a weekly podcast and
people kind of getting to know you
through this after watching you for so
long and kind of maybe not knowing as
much I think when I first started doing
YouTube stuff I was very much like you
where it's like my content is comedy
first and then maybe personal endeavors
here and there like second or third I
wanted people to laugh when they saw me
I wanted people to find an escape when
they watched anything and then I found
myself I watch reality TV I'm interested
in people's personal lives and so
naturally as I've gotten older - I've
become a little less give a [ __ ] about
putting out more personal things but
within reason you know there's always
that constant struggle of like is this
self serving to put so much like out
there and also managing expectations of
an audience like if you start to put out
that you're doing fitness stuff then
people are gonna be holding you
accountable for doing Fitness stuff and
I don't really want strangers holding me
accountable for something that I don't
have fully online yeah that's right so
it's a full balance and I think it kind
it changes for everyone that's why I
always get fascinated talking to people
like you about like what's your take on
this like where are your boundaries it's
basically like do you have boundaries
and where if so where are they I have no
every really every line is blurred I
feel like at 2014 2015 everyone knew
kind of the boundary to stick to well
nowadays every boundary is blurred and
it's bored just let's hope this doesn't
get copyright strike or let's hope I
don't get banned and you know they're
it's a it's a massive guessing game with
with the fitness stuff you know I used
to be like 195 pounds which is solid I'm
happy with but I was also like muscular
and lean it was great but then 2018-2019
I really
20:17 I got a really nasty car accident
which left me intensive care for a while
and then 2018 I would in and out a
hospital for anxiety attacks which is
not fun so I put on 50 pounds on
accident I remember look at myself in
the mirror going holy [ __ ] because
there's a month were you you don't you
don't work out you don't care about
anything and all of a sudden you're
getting burgers every day and yeah it's
gonna catch up with you you don't even
realize and then you look at yourself
and go how the [ __ ] did I even do that
how did I get here yeah and like I was
reading comment sections like Oh many
loads so fat now so I told myself okay I
need to try and get back to where I was
so as of now I'm down 20 pounds I'm down
to 230 and it's just slowly chipping
away and cuz it's sad being able to wake
up and look at yourself and go what
happened here you know yeah I mean I
think we've all hit a point like that
too and it always hurts when you read
the comments and it's stuff you already
know about yourself but you really
haven't come to terms with yourself
other people are like agreeing with you
you're like you know telling me anything
I don't know already but thank you for
calling out the obvious right now but I
think that's awesome of you to be able
to kind of recognize that and still like
see the positives of wanting to get back
to a place that makes you happy because
the byproduct of you feeling good about
yourself is that your content feels
better and people find a better
connection with like your general
persona in that sense hmm because I you
know the Internet is so silly and sneaky
because people can read between every
line and they can see between every fake
smile and really know what's going on so
you can't hide anything I think the
Internet is you're saying about how they
can read the line but my my experience
the internet now is even just seeing it
from afar is people reads to the Lions
between two lines that aren't even there
like yeah say for example you're like
wow I love this black shirt whoa you
can't say black anymore it's like yeah
it's a colour how else do I describe
this shirt you're like oh I love the I
love this yellow Hat's like what's wrong
the green hats huh you're like I guess I
yeah that's interesting
and I think it must be even more
stressful in because you do a lot of
like live gaming and live streaming on
Twitch and things like that so you are
live you can't edit yourself in post so
you have to be very choice with the
words that you're using and it's as raw
as you can get honestly and that's a
skill like have you do you feel like
you've kind of honed that over time yeah
I mean I think it's the one place that
twitch streamers fall up is actually
sitting the n-word when there's someone
there singing songs you go watch
compilation you can see as soon as they
say it you watch their face drop and
they know this is about to be a
shitstorm even if they're singing along
to like a rap song or something like
that whereas it's fine for them to do it
but obviously as a Caucasian you can't
like even silly things like whenever I
listen to a song that has the n-word in
it oh I'll just say [ __ ] instead so it
doesn't sound right but I know if I'm
listening to the song and I'm singing
along on stream my brains already
programmed to say [ __ ] it's that's
that's good which is so stupid but it
prevents me from having my entire
channel career career course okay we're
going to take a quick break when we get
back I have a bunch more questions for
you then we have some Twitter questions
we'll be right back
[Music]
too deep did you know that there's a
company that's mastered the science of
sparkle meat lightbox lab-grown diamonds
they hacked a billion-year process to
grow stunning lab-grown diamond stones
in about two weeks and they're some of
the highest quality stones that exist
they're always near colorless always vs
clarity always a very good cut and
always $800 per carat they come in three
colors to white blush pink and soft blue
after they're grown in the lab they're
transformed into gorgeous lab-grown
diamond jewelry it's Beauty meets brain
go to light box jewelry calm slash Grace
and use code grace for $25 off that's
light box jewelry dot-com slash grace
use code grace for $25 off to deep
sports research is your one-stop shop
for a lifetime of performance health and
wellness through the makers of the
highest rated collagen peptide product
on Amazon and their flagship product
sweet sweat sweating helps burn calories
and sweet sweat activated by your
elevated heart rate helps increase
sweating during exercise look at this
science you can simply apply the gel
which comes in a variety of pleasing
sense too slow to respond problem areas
before your workout for best results use
sweet sweat in combination with sports
researches best-selling waist trimmers
like their new neon waist trimmer
collection and did you know that
collagen is vital to help support the
health of your skin hair nails and
connective tissues well that's why you
should try sports researches third party
certified and non-gmo verified collagen
peptides which provide the best product
at the best price offered in a variety
of flavors sports research collagen
peptides can be added to coffee soup
sauces or more at home or on the go look
at all of these treasures for you and
you have a special offer coming your way
if you go to sport research calm and use
the code grace at checkout right now
you'll get 20% off your order that's 20%
off site-wide at sports research comm
with code grace at checkout
okay Craig let's talk about music okay
so is that this is what you studied when
you head of your brief flirtation with
school yeah my original plan in life was
to make jingles for commercials that's
why I wanted to do yeah I wanted to be
like a real-life Uncle Jesse and uncle
Joey from Full House yes 20 million
dollars like that that was my plan Wow I
mean I think that's great so so that so
you wanted to write jingles how is that
still in your brain is it still
something you fantasize about not really
I mean for the last five or so years
I've kind of put it on the back burner
but only really in the last two years
I've maybe three I'm really sort of get
back into it and just with our rugby
days I've got really into like EDM music
dance music because that's what you
listen to the gym - can I get yourself
going get yourself up so now I've kind
of taken a turn and I'm trying to
release house music this year so I'm
finally finally getting my ducks in a
row I'm finally like pull my finger I
have going okay let's just jump into the
deep end let's figure it out we've
always been so nervous about releasing
music because I know with the audience
that I have already that people are
gonna be hypercritical
I can't just realized our [ __ ] and then
get constructive criticism and then
slowly work up like I did my YouTube
channel it's more of like I released
music and I'm right in the deep end so I
couldn't really spent years ago but I
just I just held off well good for you
you want it to be quality what do you
say to people that think DJ's are just
people that push the play button I mean
they huh
I remember I was learning about learning
how to you see DJ's and I've done like
I've done DJ streams and I think the
best part about DJing is whenever you
know how to DJ and you watch other DJ's
do it like they're doing like like
they're playing with the buttons and
they're doing this with their hands
they're doing nothing really it's fun
most the time like whenever really do
this they're just flicking their hands
to make it seem like they do more I'm
like how'd it be a professional DJ is
pretending you're doing more than you
it's just religion it has it's just like
sleight of hand magic tricks I mean
they're obviously our DJ's who you know
they they completely rip songs apart and
they do everything on the fly and that's
a whole different skill set but for a
lot of DJ's you were just going on tour
it's just play song mix in play song mix
in play song mix in it pays the bills
but the whole production side of it
that's a whole different ballgame that
takes that's a lot of talents be able to
do that yeah what's your creative
process when you go into making music is
it all based on a feeling do you want to
show us a story yeah
really there's a lot of thing I don't
know how familiar with the kind of dance
music world but there's a lot of music
nowadays where a lot of people will just
make music just for the drum because
they know the drops get played at
festivals but the rest of the song
there's no there's no melodic elements
there's nothing it's just vanilla
there's nothing else there the drop is
spent you know there's hours and hours
spent on the drop but there's nothing
else wells for me you know whenever I
listen to a song I know it sounds stupid
but I want to listen to the song the
whole way through yeah well a lot of
people nowadays don't do that it's sad
so my thing is I try and write a drum
pattern or a melody or I get like a bass
line and then I just figured out from
there this coffee is hitting me but it's
just I try and get something down and
then work off that one layer okay that I
mean that seems to go hand in hand with
why you like video games you're telling
a story you're the you're manifesting
your own destiny anyway that's very cool
as a side note when is this coming out
the 25th of May perfect so that means I
get to say that I am releasing my first
song in the 27th so two days after this
goes live just let the will see a people
thing when it comes out it's technically
it's a collab so I I did a 27 days to
end up tour last year and then after the
stand-up tour I added my DJ Frank
ghastly he came out from Arizona Houston
wash the Houston show and then we flew
back to Portland together lived in
Portland for a year and then move back
here four months ago and we just wrote a
song and wrote the song oh six months
and then now his albums coming out he's
like hey I want to release it as a
single off the album hell yeah
if anything he's kind of pulling this
guy wrong he's pulling my finger out for
me like he's grabbing a hand he's going
for himself congratulations that's very
exciting you can't just jump in uh
talking about your stand-up tour what
was that like oh I missed tour so much
oh yeah you do so much stuff online and
you you see all these user names you see
number accounts and they are kind of
arbitrary and then you do live stuff you
actually see the faces of these
usernames and these numbers right that's
such a crazy experience it's for me I've
always been super interested in stand-up
I grew up watching stand out I've always
been fast again it's very story driven I
don't know I think the aim of this
podcast is realizing that like oh I just
like stories crazy like stories and
podcast and for me what I live by and I
say this never podcast is
I want a million stories my grandkids so
it's all it's all cool to say you know I
was a youtuber but let's be honest
youtubers doesn't have a really great
wrap any more for the media it's kind of
shunned on a little bit like be fair I
don't know if it ever had a great rep
but now it is it's went from I'm a
youtuber what - you're a youtuber are
you one of the bad ones
no no not one of them are you like a
Paul no no yay exactly so it's a it's a
whole different ball game now I mean
obviously I know that you know that as
well yeah but so okay so you did how
many dates that stand up 20 27 in a row
but I did one practice show in LA so 20
alone that's so intense do you even
remember any of it
if you were telling me like oh think
back to Philadelphia I can have like a
picture in my mind but because every
show was relatively the same you know it
was just it was just going through the
motions again um but you know I said
before I want a million stories for my
grandkids I could just be a youtuber and
sit at home but I want to go experience
things you know like now that I'm young
I want to be able to travel I want to be
able to get to know places like
especially mean up being American doing
a tour getting a tour bus and driving
around America and then one day in
Canada it just it made my life complete
as a lot people were like why are you
doing why are you doing 27 tour dates
not just seven like a normal person on
their first tour it's like I want to
travel I realize that the venue's will
be smaller because people are more
spread out but for me it's not about
it's not about the size of the venue
it's about experiencing it and like
you're in Philadelphia yeah I go to
Philadelphia getting like the place
where uh Philly cheesesteaks were made
we're getting New York Pizza Mia playing
Times Square like that to me was a wild
like that thing where when I'm like 60
years old I get to be the cool uncle not
the creepy uncle and I mean I guess yeah
slight there yeah there's only a very
slight difference so big hair flies are
blurred weather
completely bonkers moments that stand
out to you from tour any likes and
interactions
I think what's funny is there was there
people in the crowd who just didn't care
about like stage setting so like they
would like they come to the show
thinking that they're the star of the
show so yeah running up on stage and
like there's people there was a guy in
Toronto who's the first show and we're
like okay first show we have to nail
this it was like 12 other people in the
crowd it was fantastic
we went out there were 30 minutes in and
when you noticed this guy and a bright
neon shirt bright neon pants bright neon
shoes he's fortnight dancing for an hour
and a half like like we kept bringing
him up we just called him fortnight guy
we're like Jesus fortnight guy you're
still he's like oh my god energy hog did
you do before coming into this venue I
know wow I mean I guess it's kind of a
compliment but also like but it is
interesting to have to sort of coach an
audience on the etiquette in like a
stand-up show versus like a VidCon
experience I've never been to VidCon and
it's great just because it scares me
because every time I see VidCon I mean
you could probably jump into this but
it's like I
I see VidCon and every VidCon there's
always some stupid youtuber doing some
stupid thing I'm like I don't want to be
a part of that yeah no you're you're
okay you you've gotten the experience by
doing your own live shows it's a it's a
very anxiety-ridden overwhelming
experience to say please well speaking
of stories that you want to tell your
grandchildren you interact with a lot of
high-profile people recently you've been
talking with Jack Black and you and Elon
Musk have liked it as seemingly like
Twitter romance happening my twitter has
exploded okay between for you because
because let me just remember that after
this tweet I had news
orders sliding to my DMS following me my
business email saying Elon Musk talk to
you what do you know you know insider
information I told and I told Eli must
have put an anime flag on the moon mhm
and that's it and like hey LM us can you
put a anime flight on the moon no real
reason just pretty funny he was like
alright and now I have people spam me
saying do you know the secrets of Tesla
or why their stock prices are doing this
I'm like bro I like anime titties like I
just well I want that on the surface of
the Moon that's literally it
I don't know [ __ ] yeah are you there are
you the Godfather of their new baby now
what's going on I don't know anymore I
just wish they'd stop I do
Wall Street Journal I don't know
anything please stop messaging me oh
that's amazing
okay is there a celebrity that's on your
wish list to collab with or have any
sort of interaction with that you
haven't already I think what theme is
I've never really been one to fanboy or
fangirl I've never been that person you
know like for me every time I meet
someone I always know that they're just
person who just you know for some reason
a lot of people think like if when you
hit like a certain status that you don't
have to do basic human things anymore
like people legitimately ask me like do
you have to [ __ ] anymore I'm like
because I know they're just a regular
person with regular needs and doing
whatever they want they're just really
good at their job and that's about it so
not really his you know I don't know how
people actually are I've see them for
movies or you know their musical
performances or things like that I don't
know how they're like in their real life
you know I could love their movies it
could be a fuck-boy so I'm down for I'm
down for whatever really I'm not trying
to like bring people and that's great
okay do you have free time ever what do
you do to because I know I can all be
kind of the same thing because basically
your hobbies
your job which is a blessing and a curse
in a lot of ways what do you do to relax
to unwind you watch shows do you like do
you follow any Instagram accounts that
bring you like joy in any way oh really
I mean I follow Instagram I follow a
bodybuilder Instagram accounts to make
me feel worse than I actually am but a
whole are from that it's you know what
youtubers i watch I don't really watch
any youtubers but I watch a few and
they're like their documentary style
youtubers so you know so I imagine like
like a Vsauce style video but they're
like 10 minute chunks like there's one
I'm gonna show brights on films he has
like less than a million subscribers but
he has a show called abandoned and it's
a show where it's ten minute chunks and
he tells you why this building or this
park or whatever way out of business and
what it looks like it's really
interesting and it's just it just
appeases me that's really it you know
I'm not looking to laugh no do anything
I'm just like that's pretty cool and
then I move on with my day but you know
whilst I'm watching that I have my
laptop open I'm trying to write music or
or do something like that or answer
emails or this thing or that thing so it
never really stops because even when you
go to Twitter like being you know that's
like Twitter or Instagram everyone goes
back after a long day and they go on
social media to unwind but because
they're unwind is our job
whenever you go on social media you're
thinking what can I tweet what can I do
here can I interact with this person
whatever the hell it's always going
through your brain so it just it doesn't
stop tow I feel the same way that's why
I've lit Twitter to me is like a place
that I've I go to collect news and I
feel you know internet ly responsible
for checking in on it but it does bring
me a little stress every time I think
about what to contribute on that
platform is there a social media
platform that you enjoy more than others
like what's the first thing you go to on
your phone or on your computer
probably YouTube just not even to watch
it but just to see when I can upload
little gaps to make sure I can upload it
a good time or like you know I'll try
and like make sure that I'm not caught
blocking someone like one of my friends
who I know how
like similar fans same fan bases
whatever so like I'll make sure that my
friend uploads five minutes earlier that
I wait a little bit to make sure that he
can get the views that he wants and then
they're done with their video and then
they can come to mine
that's very respectful I feel like you
know there's obviously a lot of youtuber
through it bigger than me and there's a
lot of youtubers who are smaller than me
I'm kind of like right in the middle so
if I make sure that if it's a youtuber
that's smaller than me that I make sure
they can get the views because I know
that you know everyone needs to pay
bills especially with CPMs dropping like
seventy five percent that's great isn't
there some kind of etiquette in surfing
where you like let the person go in
front of you that's been waiting longer
than you or something like that I know
it's been years since you were a major
surf community guy but I've never surfed
on the ocean so the front of a surfing
channel is brilliant you really to date
never size in the ocean I body boarded
but that doesn't count I try to stand up
on the body board like when I tell
people like yourself I have a surfing
channel all of a sudden they're
imagining me I'm kid on the ocean Hawaii
or my [ __ ] and waiting line I love
it I love it that's so fantastic okay
before we take one last break thoughts
on aliens
pretty chill
I mean do they exist of course they do
there's no way there's no way the
universe is that bank without aliens
existing you know yeah I think it's
really selfish of us to assume that were
the only living beings in this world
yeah exactly it's kind of ignorant to
the fact that the world or the universe
is way bigger than anyone expects you
know we have to be but we have to have
oxygen the perfect distance away from
the Sun and the perfect distance away
from everything who's not to say that
that's not happening in some place a
hundred thousand light years away it
probably and they're probably looking
for the same thing too like oh really
and we're over here like hi I know we
can't talk to you but we're here like
different iterations of that totally
totally totally it's like it's a social
distancing it's you're you're in your
house alone you don't know if your
neighbor oh what a great way to put that
okay we're gonna take one last break
we'll be get back we have some Twitter
questions for usually right back we're
not too deep if you're struggling with
stress anxiety isolation or depression
right now you are not alone
I have had one if not all of these
feelings going on in my brain right now
and here's something that can help
better help offers online licensed
professional counselors who can help
their counselors specialize in issues
like depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self-esteem and more you can connect
with your counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is completely confidential what
you do is you fill out a questionnaire
to help assess your needs and you get
matched with the counselor in less than
24 hours you can easily schedule secure
video or phone sessions with your
therapist plus you can exchange
unlimited messages which I've had
friends use this service before and
that's one of the most amazing things
the most convenient things is that you
can text with your therapist or your
counselor at your own convenience at
your
time it's super super easy if for any
reason you're unhappy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
any time for no additional charge and
it's truly an affordable option but on
top of that you guys will get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace that's better help calm go to
better help be et te RHEL p.com slash
Grace and use the code grace for 10% off
your first month talk to a therapist
online and get help do you a bunch of
stuff lying around the house that you
just don't use we've all been in our
houses and all we've had time for is
looking at all the things that we've
amassed and collected for ourselves and
most of it you probably don't use so
here's something that can help you out
I'm talking about stuff like a kids
baseball glove that doesn't fit a pair
of jeans you wore one time and then you
know they just didn't work out an old
phone in a drawer we all have that
random phone and that random drawer I
know you do I do well there's an app
that can help you sell this stuff it's
called Macari Macari is the selling app
that makes it fast and easy to sell
almost anything it couldn't be simpler
you take a few pics of your stuff you
add a description and boom your item is
listed then once it's sold my car emails
you a shipping label and you just stick
it on and send it off there's no meetups
there's no hassles with millions of
people using the Macario app in all 50
states your stuff will really sell the
app has over 600,000 reviews on the App
Store with an average 4.8 star rating so
why not give it a try
I mean if you're gonna have all this
free time in your house on your hands
you may as well you know spark some joy
for yourself don't let that stuff you
don't use go two-way sell or buy almost
anything on Macari you can find Macari
on the App Store's or on Morcar e-comm
that's em er CA RI Macari the selling
app okay Craig before we get into these
Twitter questions I'm going to ask you
the two questions asked every single
guest that is on the podcast the first
is who alive or dead would you most like
to throw cold spaghetti at home
Old Spaghetti cold spaghetti call that's
all okay
is this spaghetti like has it been in a
pot and it's noodley and then you throw
it or is it like the hard strands where
you just spear people I mean you can
make it whatever you want I always
imagined that it's been cooked and it's
more like leftovers hmm sorry I like
that the the texture of the spaghetti is
really what's defining for you who it
gets thrown by trying to insult someone
or kill them why it's it's your
intention it can also be celebratory you
can throw it into joy a moment of joy a
moment of praise you want a cold throw
cold spaghetti yeah and this is an
answer that obviously changes on a
regular basis for people it's just who
at this current moment I feel like I've
asked you very serious questions and
you've answered them like so quickly and
the one that it's completely irreverent
you're like I gotta think about this can
I do Kim jong-un back in the spaghetti
be hard and so I can stab him you can
make those choices for yourself
absolutely perfect wet spaghetti
oh you can also think about it and come
back to it later if you want to ruin it
myself and cry yeah and that of course I
can see you doing that in a video
immediately probably I mean I have a
second kawaii microwave behind me like
anything is possible I have a tender ass
downstairs
I don't have a giant giraffe head in my
house oh yeah I feel like it's a
necessity for all content creators oh
well for me it was just my audience
bullying me saying hey there's a $1,300
10-foot giraffe on Amazon I bet you
won't buy it I'm like you're right I'm
not going to a month went by of just my
community going do it do it I was like
[ __ ] I bought it let me warriors let me
see if I can pull up the the box that
was at the door cuz I feel like you'd
appreciate this oh please it came in a
giant box I've been for any neighbors
that you have I'm sure that was a
beautiful moment for them and also
horrified last part is I was recording
cuz I was like 6:00 in the morning and I
was I was heading out on my second herb
was the first like a second like I
remember well I was dragging in this
track and my neighbor saw me so in my
video you can see me waving to my
neighbors as I dragon this beautiful and
that's how you become that guy in the
neighborhood oh I've already been that
guy I strive to be that guy
perfect while you're looking for that
I'm gonna ask you and you can think on
this the other question I ask every
single guest that is on the podcast and
it's to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so for example mine is college
jogging front lawn
a pregnant pause
Australia Oh 16 shopping cart Oh a
picture Oh
oh my god Wow that's the box that the
giraffe came and that is so yeah look at
this Christmas sure Christmas present
means really I wonder what it is I
wonder if it's a bike it also looks like
it could be a body like it looks like it
could be something very terrifying Wow I
thought it was gonna be just a
straight-up giant box but and there is I
mean yeah you made a good purchase yeah
I will side with your audience and say
I'm really glad that they peer pressured
you into getting that piece of art
exhibits great it is our and then I
bought I bought bamboo because he has a
little bit of leaves coming out of his
mouth so I bought him a giant bamboo
plant so he looks like he's feeding at
all times even though after giraffes are
African and bamboo is not Wow I mean but
the the paternal energy is there you
really want to provide for your new
tribe for having you know my
ex-girlfriend and two dogs living with
me
- now I'm feeding a stuffed giraffe
bamboo yeah I I think people would say
that your mental health is right perfect
right in the middle like exactly right
and exactly wrong perfect okay let's get
into these Twitter questions sure
someone's asking what's the game that
you get the most feedback from when
playing okay okay feedback as in like
well they're also asking and is the
feedback more tips on the game or are
they encouraging comments
like what's the most like interaction I
guess the game that prompts people to
interact with you I would say GTA the
reason being is it's the the open world
is so massive and what me and my friends
did is the reason we all blew up is GTA
is very linear like mission mission
mission mission end well because the
world is so open we tried to find like
mini games you can do with your friends
so like for example there is a garden
maze in GTA so we made murder-mystery
where one person has a knife you turn
off all the HUD and you just have to
hide in this garden maze there's things
like tank rodeo someone gets a tank they
spin around the barrel I need to try and
stay on for five seconds life falling
off like we leave minigames so people
can play with their own friends and
that's that's completely where we blew
up so even now I got a lot of feedback
saying you know oh I had this idea we
did it with my friends I would love to
see you do it
I like this idea that idea or what if
you did this what if you did that a lot
of videos it's people like I love you or
go [ __ ] yourself
GTA it's the only thing in the world all
Battin vlogs but so anything in the
world people are like actually trying to
help oh that's nice oh that's very end
of minigames obviously goes straight
into the brand makes the most sense
exactly with that someone wants to know
what's the best and worst multiplayer
games to film or stream ok so the way I
describe games is they're fun games and
there's fun knee games so fun games are
like destiny to valor --nt where they're
really really fun to actually play but
they're not good to watch it's kind of
boring to watch it's not really much to
do boss there's fun knee games like gang
beasts which not many people have heard
of if you're not really in gaming you
point ok because it's blown up but like
yeah and my boyfriend had me play with
him and for someone that doesn't know
any games somehow I know that game yeah
it's because it's so stupid yeah
hilarious to watch yes I have like a
funny game where it's not triple-a title
it's an indie game it's kind of small
but the actual content they it's a mean
game you know it's generates a lot of
good content so
it's kind of hard to say the best game I
think for content is like a GTA where
you can mess around or a gang beefs
where you can mess around but the games
I love playing but I can't actually
record as Valerie got it yeah I mean
cool but that makes sense
I get the categories and I can see as
someone that would be watching someone
play a game watching gang beast is much
more fun than watching you do just the
actual way the game is played yeah for
me before I started youtube I used to go
on glitching forums like I was on those
guys I find glitches for games well I
tell you I'm a [ __ ] nerd grace like
oh my god I'm a travesty that's great
that makes you appreciate the gaming
world so much more because that's how
deeply you care about it exactly it's
fun it's stupid and that's all I'm
really looking for and any kind of
content you know I realize that my
personality can be Miche it's very
stupid it's very all over the place but
you know I could try and be someone else
potentially get more subscribers and
more views whenever bless not me you
know it's easy maybe me just to [ __ ]
around and you know like my humor isn't
universal but it's fun what a beautiful
phrase it's so much easier to be me I'm
lazy [ __ ] not really when you talk about
how much you do you're really not very
lazy so give yourself some credit
okay I appreciate that okay last Twitter
question before we we have a little gift
for you at the very end um in your
honest honest opinion what's the worst
thing that you've done during quarantine
oh this is a tough one went outside no
what's the worst thing I've done I'll
say the worst thing I've done just worse
than that it's like so silly
I got a scratch-off ticket and I'll I
sold it like crazy because I I'm like I
have trash taste and so I love
scratch-off so much or scratchers or
whatever people call them and yeah I was
like very seriously cleaning it before I
actually played the scratcher because I
was so dedicated to it staying clean and
making yeah yeah
sure I got my fix but I didn't get
coronavirus at the same time it's weird
for me because May or March 6th I had a
giant my roof caved in in my living room
at it was leaking it was crazy it was
all over the place and even now to this
day there's still a hole in my ceiling
because workers can't come over and fix
it so I literally just have like a tarp
around the hole and a bucket and I just
pray it doesn't rain because I know it's
gonna leak into the living room my task
tears right now is just covered in
plastic and the couches are all the side
nothing's anywhere it looks like
Dexter's Laboratory in your living room
no it looks like a coronavirus themed
party you can go into this tarp and like
sound like a [ __ ] picture booth oh
god well that's a tree that's a real fun
thing Craig thank you for being here
this has been so fun before you leave we
like to give a little gift to every
guest that has made time for us and
Melissa will be sending it to you
usually we in person we have a
personalized fortune cookie that's made
for our guests but we have a digital
fortune cookie
but Melissa should be sending to you
currently all of us okay cool and if you
would do us the pleasure of reading your
fortune out loud that would be wonderful
in light of your recently leaking
ceiling may we offer the wise Persian
proverb a drowning man is not troubled
by rain I hope that makes you feel
better I you know as a guy is not trying
to drown I don't hate your roof is
horrifically broken try not to drown in
your own mess lots of layers there okay
Craig where can everyone find you if
they don't already know yeah so YouTube
there's two channels I have the gaming
channel which is mail-id I have my vlog
stuff which is Craig Thompson music I'll
be releasing under Craig Thompson songs
coming out in two days he monetized tour
will be next year because a current a
virus and my own podcast is coming out
soon
I didn't get to ask you about that but I
heard ruminations that this was
something you wanted to do so it's
actually happening thank you thank you
again so much this was very fun and I
learned a lot so I been great
of course all right guys go check out
everything that craig is up to make sure
you get that music because he's gotta
keep doing it and the only way he does
apparently is by your peer pressure so
exactly to be pulling the finger out of
my ass that's that's why I want you to
do on that no we'll see you guys next
time on not too deep goodbye I too deep
too deep
go deep not too deep was Christ Harry
Beck not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa D months edited by Shireen
Lonnie Eunice post production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]